i did an embroidery to that respect
which i called something over the
rainbow went uh somewhere over the
rainbow something went terribly wrong
and uh
because i felt like i need to elaborate
a little bit more what this is about
which i usually don't necessarily do
with my work i wrote a blog post with 5
000 words
um explaining what i think has gone
wrong there were a lot of people who
immediately got very upset with me but
the essence of it was really just me
saying
i think we need to talk about this you
can't just waltz in and say trance
rights are trans rights and so we should
be able to do all the things that we
want to do
there has to be a debate because i think
there are competing rights here and
everything i came against up against was
there's no debate no debate competing
rights in in terms of threatening women
to a certain extent so
like for example rape shelters in my
opinion should be single sex um
that's not to say that there shouldn't
be shelters that also cater for trans
people um but i think there's a there's
a good
reason to keep certain spaces single sex
prisons is another thing that should be
single sex
um and so no i'm not saying that trans
people shouldn't get all those spaces
too but they shouldn't we we shouldn't
pretend that humans can change sex so
you put this post out yeah and what
happened
uh people got really quickly really
upset which i knew would be happening so
i had a theoretical concept of what the
backlash would be like but it was
actually really really horrific when it
did happen so like two weeks after
posting the blog post um when i still
had a
little hair salon inside of soho theater
at the time
um
for two weeks i was just walking around
numb because it just felt horrific it's
like a really it's really abstract
concept of what it would feel like if
people start to hound you i had people
from
the states and canada trying to call me
in the middle of the night i haven't had
my phone on
out of sleep mode since then essentially
which is more than two years ago now um
because just random people would find my
number which was still online at the
time because of my hairdressing business
that i had at the time so they would
find my number they would email me they
would um
start harassing silver theater basically
pressuring them to let go of the
transphobe that they were harboring and
such things do you think this is
a generational thing i mean
i think that's too simplistic to say
that it's a generational thing because
i've seen older people who should know
much better um
chime in with the nonsense so
maybe it's instigated as a generational
thing but i think it's a combination of
a lot of factors
lots of things feed into this it's the
social media it's helicopter parenting
which in a way is also understandable
because if you look at the internet and
what it exposes kids to nowadays it's
just like a hot bed off
so i think it's all of that it's the
idea that um well it's not just an idea
the fact that students have become
consumers like they expect people to um
you know like to teach as lecturers to
perform a job duty so they're not going
to universities anymore to learn but
actually to just get their
ideas regurgitated i mean you're
surprised that it's been taken up by so
many institutions i mean on left and
right this this this idea of you know
people who would say
you know for expressing the views you
have you are transphobic and therefore
you should be cancelled i was very
surprised and and i think i was really
blind to it as well because it's
happened so uh quickly and quietly
um but now because i've been
dealing with it now for more than three
years almost daily i'm no longer
surprised because the tactics that have
been used with this entire no debate no
debate is kind of almost what got us
here the other ring of anybody who dares
to
um question even just question not even
taking a statement um so no i mean those
tactics they're almost a bit like
like i'm from formerly east berlin
they're very sort of like cold war
nonsense you know it's very
it feels very strategic and i think
stonewall has been really instrumental
in lobbying for this you know and to get
people to shut up and to um position to
other anybody who who does question
things and so it's just a really toxic
environment and so it it
stonewall and their diversity scheme has
so many uh institutions where they're
part of now so that doesn't surprise me
anymore you know like the involvement is
so great and people generally i think
want to do the right thing and the good
thing and they've been sold that this is
the right and the good thing and the
others you know the big bad
feminists they are the the
you know the evils do you think we are
going to get out of this or do you think
we have to
we have to i mean what's the alternative
the alternative is some authoritarian
hellscape um
where people tell you
how you have to refer to someone's
preferred pronouns and you can lose your
job i mean already now the amount of
emails that i'm getting from people that
say that they absolutely support me
and i mean the support has been huge
um but that they couldn't say what i say
but i understand why a lot of people
can't speak up that in and of itself
should
shake people awake who wants to live in
a pla like that's no longer democratic
is it i mean
yeah i
i don't dare to think of the
alternatives